(bright music)
- [Narrator] Title 42,
the pandemic-era policy
that allowed US authorities
to quickly expel migrants
on public health grounds has expired.
The Biden administration
has deployed 1,500
active duty troops at the southern border
to assist the border patrol
with processing as fears
of a significant surge
of migrants grow.
Wall Street Journal's
Alicia A. Caldwell reports
from El Paso, Texas and
explains what Title 42 is,
the effect it has had on the
border and what comes next.
- Title 42 is a public
health law that was used
by the Trump administration
to quickly remove
or expel migrants who
crossed the border illegally,
intending to ask for asylum.
- [Narrator] The policy's
name comes from Title 42
of the US Legal Code which is
a body of public health laws.
The Trump administration
began using it in March, 2020
to turn back migrants on grounds
that they might bring
COVID-19 into the US.
Under the policy, most
migrants were sent back
to Mexico after border patrol
agents recorded their names
and fingerprints.
- Border Patrol and the US
government has been quick
to point out it was
not an immigration law,
so it carried with it no
immigration penalties.
- [Narrator] The measure proved to be far
from an ideal enforcement tool.
It had the unexpected result
of making it easier
for non-asylum migrants
to attempt repeated border crossings.
- So if you got caught, got returned,
you live to see another day in terms
of your immigration opportunity or chance
to cross the border illegally
again and make it through.
(crowd chatter)
- [Narrator] Authorities had
already recorded big increases
in illegal crossings leading
up to Title 42's expiration.
(crowd chant slogans in foreign language)
In March, cities like El Paso
experienced a 54% increase
in border patrol encounters,
compared to the same period last year.
Looking at the southwest border overall,
total encounters increased
25% in the same period.
The change in border policy
has also created confusion among migrants.
- There's tremendous disinformation
and smugglers have an interest
in pushing people across the border now.
- I want to be very clear,
our borders are not open.
People who cross our border unlawfully
and without a legal basis to remain
will be promptly processed and removed.
- [Narrator] The governors of
Arizona and Texas have said
that the Biden administration's
policies inadequately
secure the border, leaving them to bear
the brunt of the migrant waves.
- President Biden is
laying down a welcome mat
to people across the entire world,
saying that the United
States border is wide open,
and it would lead to an incredible amount
of people coming across
the border illegally.
- [Narrator] The Secretary
of Homeland Security,
Alejandro Mayorkas said the administration
is employing a combination
of existing immigration laws
and a new set of measures to
address the migrant surge.
(door thuds)
- People who arrive at our
southern border will be subject
to our immigration enforcement authorities
under Title 8 of the United States Code.
- Title 8 is an immigration law
and does carry penalties.
It is technically a
misdemeanor to cross the border
without permission and those who do
and are returned, face a five-year ban
from returning to the country illegally.
And if they do return and they get caught,
they can face a felony charge
for crossing the border again.
- [Narrator] The Biden
administration's new set
of measures is intended to mimic
the Title 42 border policy.
Migrants who enter the US illegally,
which asylum seekers are
allowed to do under current law
will be quickly subjected
to a higher asylum standard.
- Those who cross
illegally and haven't asked
for protections in other countries
prior to their arrival here, by and large,
won't be eligible.
They'll face swift deportation.
- [Narrator] And they
will be deported back
to their home countries or back to Mexico,
which has agreed to keep taking them.
The administration also plans
to open new migrant processing centers
in Guatemala and Colombia to
create some legal pathways
for asylum seekers.
Yet it's unclear when
the centers would open
or how much impact they will have.
- They're also pushing people
to use the CBP One app.
It's an app that you can
make an appointment to come
to a legal border
crossing, a port of entry,
and make your case to
enter the United States.
- [Narrator] Asylum Seekers
at the border will be
essentially barred from
entering the country
under the rules, unless they use
the app's appointment system.
- (Michael speaks foreign language)
- If you have a real mix of people
who are trying to use this
app with some success,
and others saying that they
just can't wait any longer
in making the track.
The expectation is that a lot
of people will simply
make the effort to cross
and see what happens.
- (Reyna speaks foreign language)
- (Reporter speaks foreign language)
(bright music)